Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to.
Oh, I don't know.
Why don't we try George from Chicago.
George, you're on the air.
That's my audio.
Your audio is maybe about a six and a half,
seven, not bad.
Speaker 2: Oh, all right, well, David.
Speaker 1: Oh, I'm sorry, your audio just
dropped to a five.
Speaker 2: Oh, oh, geez, I'm sorry.
I'll try to get real quick, OK?
Yeah, please.
OK, David, I heard an article in the comments
that talked about rising or some of the stimulus
preventing people from going into the workforce.
Do you think it's a little bit too soon to
say whether or not that's a good call to do
that story yet?
Speaker 1: Yeah, so I did a segment about
this earlier this week and spent about, you
know, 10 or 15 minutes talking about it.
Here's my view on this, because I think this
is really important.
It's a very popular right wing argument right
now to say because of the enhanced unemployment,
people are just raking in money by not working.
And so this is causing all these restaurants
to be unable to hire people.
And here's the bottom line, enhanced unemployment
benefits.
And and I think it's September 6th, but it's
I believe sometime in September, once that
happens, all sorts of people that right now
might be choosing not to go back to work because
if they go back to work, they might make the
same or a little less or whatever because
of the enhanced unemployment.
They're going to need to go and get get jobs.
They're just going to need to go and do it.
Unemployment's going to end.
And it's very easy to just look at a social
welfare program and point to what you would
consider to be the free riders or people taking
advantage of it, making more off of the program
than from work.
But that's going to come to an end.
And hence, unemployment was hugely beneficial
to the country at a macroeconomic level.
And in the next three to four months, I believe
this is going to resolve itself.
George's people are going to need jobs.
There's going to be no more unemployment,
and some businesses will have to pay more.
And there's no question about it.
And there is an argument to be made in some
states.
If you can't get people to come and work for
you, maybe you're not paying a high enough
wage.
It is true that dropping enhanced unemployment
on top of state unemployment distorts the
labor market.
That's absolutely undeniable.
The question is, is it exposing that the wages
are too low?
In some cases, the answer is yes.
And there's not a one size fits all answer
to that.
Different states have different minimum wages,
but I believe this will be resolved by October
15th.
Speaker 2: OK.
OK, thank you.
I just thought that article was a little bit
too soon and lampooned the stimulus a little
bit too much.
I agree with you.
Just a real quick question.
Yeah.
I'm going to be through whether you call it
fortunate or unfortunate circumstances, I'd
say fortunate in Boston, Massachusetts, next
week.
Anything in particular you think I should
see?
Speaker 1: Have you been to the city before?
Speaker 2: No, sir.
Speaker 1: OK, when when I would you know,
when people when I was in Boston and people
would come visit me if they had never been
before, I would sort of give them a tour that
includes the popular tourist, the area of
the Boston Common Area, a Newbury Street along
the river between Boston and Cambridge.
You definitely want to go over to Cambridge,
check out Harvard Yard, check out Amitay,
check out that area, but then also go down
to Southie and Dorchester, go to Castle Island,
go to some of these other, you know, new hip
neighborhoods.
What else?
Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, that's probably already enough for
a weekend.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right.
Speaker 1: Have a go on, David.
All right, George.
Absolutely.
A perfect phone call.
Really can't be.
We're off to a great start today.
Let's see if we can keep it going.